certainly this was uh not the worst
you've ever seen
well it's definitely not the worst but
it was the one that um
i think kind of just shocked me because
it was the first time that i've seen
actually like children involved in just
like elderly couples so it was
it may be the worst yeah so i think for
that was a a shocker and i think
um i think it'd be good to talk about it
now but you know seeing
um just like that little girl crying and
holding on to her sister then
the you know her dad pushed on to her
and she was just you know in fear for
life you have all these
grown adults screaming at them and um
you know
to be honest him that that moment took
like a mental toll
uh on me because right after that
situation happened then that brutal
knockout happened seeing the guy get
stomped out then seeing the elderly
couple
get threatened um you know for me as a
reporter i think i don't know
it never really happened to me where it
just was like it was almost like enough
was enough i was at a point where it's
like i don't even know how much more i
could show my audience anymore of
what's going on and i just it was just
too much for me you know they attacked a
caravan of trump supporters in new york
and i think it was a woman she went to a
car and pepper sprayed kids
the kids in the car she just started
spraying that's crazy
these people are deranged so you know i
think there were people who voted for
joe biden
thinking that things will go back to
normal because everything's going to go
back to normal
it's not going there's no normal this
stuff's going to get crazier
imagine if the only reason you did vote
for biden was
to put an end to the unrest and now
you've just gotten rid of the only
guy who said i will stop this exactly
what's interesting to me
is that this is now joe biden's america
if this is your president-elect
this is what your president-elect has
come up with no it's not just that it's
that joe biden should have come out and
said
i didn't i reject this violence on the
on the trump support i'm i'm going to be
the president no he didn't do it
biden did he say anything about it
nothing nothing
he's not going to be the president for
all americans he's going to be the
president for his base
that there's two as brian stelter likes
to say of cnn
alternate realities although he said i'm
not going to say alternate reality
because they live in fictional realities
okay bro i think you you live in a
fictional reality too
but it is true and i read the news all
day and it really is
when we talk scott adams put it puts it
better it's what you say one screen with
two different movies playing at the same
time
and they're two different americans and
i've been to both political campaigns
and i mean just even the voters it's a
completely different
america when you're hanging out with
each one you know what
yeah the the left likes to say oh tim
talks about civil war too much
mother jones put out an article saying
our political civil war will just keep
getting worse
that's mother jones they're a leftist
and they're saying political civil war
okay well what do you call it when
people are beating like attacking kids
and pepper spraying kids here's a
question for you in 1968 did we say
there was a civil war afoot
when the violence at the democratic
convention
that's different that's that that was
the police versus protesters
this is we're talking about two
different realities where
where the news on one side is saying
biden is president-elect kamala harris
hasn't even resigned her sentencing does
she
no not that i know of right now i think
a lot of people hated nixon
in in a 68 i mean no for sure for sure
and then you had the kent state
shootings like seven things were really
really bad the weather underground and
the bombings all over college campuses
and stuff like that and
and you know yeah this is going to
continue the one election of trump or
election of biden wasn't going to change
i've been trying to
prep people for this this notion that
this is this is just one
small skirmish the presidency the
election for the president
one small skirmish in a in a conflict
that has been going on and building for
better more than 10 15 20 years now is
going to keep going this these are
these are giant tectonic plates at work
these are
not little things that can be fixed in a
minute so there's there's this uh uh
research program called transparency
tube where they basically try and
like uh sort all the different youtube
channels
and they say that anti-woke is
right-wing
meaning you can be a socialist but as
long as you
think critical race theory antifa the
violence is the worst thing affecting
our country
they'll call you right wing that's
that's the current like
the the point is it seems like
nothing makes sense in terms of who's on
whose side other than
the tribes have been drawn and like i
said uh earlier
too tim we're we're living in the in the
realignment um
like i said that moment kind of hit me
when you know i'm on black lives matter
plaza just doing my regular reporting
and then i just see
you know all the uh liberals and
everyone just celebrating joe biden's
victory they're popping champagne
and for me i was like you guys are
popping champagne for the guy who voted
us
into the iraq war you know who was a
vocal advocate for that war then took us
from two wars to to seven i'm like what
is going what
what are we watching right now now now
the right wing is
anti-war you know i don't it's just it's
just the total real life
that we're living through it's the it's
the weirdest the
the people trying to quantify youtube
channels bless their hearts
like there's no real way to do it you
can you can straight up be like i'm all
for universal health care but man these
these violent
you know rioters are dangerous and and
the critical race there is a horrible
horrible problem and they'll be like
that's right wing
it's like so so who do i vote for
because the republicans aren't going to
be in favor of progressive policy
it's like one of the craziest things
about is they said that
if you were one-sided on the issue of
brett kavanaugh or like migrant caravans
and i'm like
so telling the truth about brett
kavanaugh is right wing
that's nuts that's where we're at
anything that you do to protect
perpetuate the male dominated patriarchy
that's oppressive to women and
minorities
no that's true right it's like you're
either racist or anti-racist you're
either
feminist or you're an anti-feminist
you're you're either progressive you're
anti-progressive you're you're doesn't
doesn't
doesn't the natural conclusion of this
just become
war yes well i think we're already at
war and that was like
when me and you met it was the first
conversation we had that night i was i
feel like this is war weariness
that people are going crazy
psychological problems
getting kids sex changes when they're
six years old
it just seems like people are going
psychotic going nuts i think it's
because we've been at war for 20 years
and we're not talking about it enough
it's honestly it's not a full-blown
culture it's it's the cultural war it's
not about
look i'm i'm mad about you know our
excursions in the middle east
but this is about there's been something
happening
and it's probably a lack of trusted
media i think
started it you know uh conservatives
particularly knew
that they weren't getting fair framing
and that's where it starts
framing right so donald trump throws the
food into the koi pond
and then everybody makes fun of him
saying what's he doing you're supposed
to put a little bit what a [ __ ]
literally the camera framed it that way
because when you zoomed out and watched
the full footage
trump was just doing what uh shinzo abe
was doing he just did
he's like when in rome you know oh he
threw the food and i'll throw the food
next they framed a certain way so
conservatives see that and say that
wasn't true that was falsely framed
so they stopped watching now it's
getting even crazier where
fox news their ratings are dropping like
crazy they're burning subscribers as
people move to newsmax
greg kelly on newsmax is getting a
million viewers at night
this is rivaling now some of the biggest
news networks it's massive
brian stelter gets all angry he's like
this is a threat to democracy these
disparate realities and it's like
within reason yes i think the bigger
threat is that the mainstream media
has given up on telling us the truth
like how many of these outlets report on
the fact that kids were being attacked
in in in dc i i haven't seen i'm being
honest i haven't seen it so people know
if you want to know the truth you can't
go to these networks
and so naturally they're going to go to
places like newsmax
i haven't seen washington post even
mention not one of those attacks
yeah no and that's why i go out in the
streets man that's why you're out there
too
is because somebody has to be there to
show to witness that's what
they confront me on the street whose
side you want whose side you want i'm
like bro i'm lit i'm here to witness
yeah
like what just just like tim if i was
out there it was trump supporters
beating up and stomping black lives
matter people i would show the public
like hey this is what trump supporters
are doing right
um but you're not a political dude yeah
in it but it it wasn't that and
see but bro this is what's funny when we
had you on the first time
uh you were with the riot squad right so
like richie and shelby
and you're like oh i'm not i'm not
really political i don't know a whole
lot about this
and it's like bro if you come out and
start saying man these these leftists
were attacking people boom you're
right-wing
that's it doesn't matter yeah i'm
already i'm already labeled with it so
uh might as well write it for full send
all right jack full set okay no cap full
set thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you